how can someone tell the time of death
what what type let's suppose it's a car
fire you know and and investigators are
coming out to an accident and there's a
decedent in the driver's seat it's been
on fire fires been extinguished what
would be how would they ask to meet the
time of death okay that ones there's
some easy questions and then hopefully
some good points that I can make out of
this one as I had mentioned earlier time
of death there's a scale a timeline of
how the body decomposes and in skeleton
eise's and mummifies and things like
that which we're not talking about here
car fire time of death would be called
perimortem there's an anti mortem period
which is when you're alive or before
death perimortem period which is around
the time of death and we would just say
this person you know died you know
perimortem from a car fire and then of
course there's anti mortem which is
after death those come in actually more
in play if I can get off the car fire
for a second those come more in play
with you know was this mark on the bone
made anti more and perimortem or
postmortem because we can tell because
the bone is green when it's fresh or as
if it's dry it's get the marks will
leave different striations different
different types of marks I'm an Aussie
ahlet's as I go back and forth
after the carbecue one of my favorite
words that has to that you would know
within you know within a half an hour
well then I guess you can actually find
that somebody that died you know you can
find the car fire three days later if
they were out in the woods that would go
into the timeline of death and
decomposition that I've mentioned before
so that would play into it and the
charred remains would have to be taken
into consideration I don't know of any
algorithms for for considering that but
we would so go under the the basic you
know
rigor mortis livor mortis lividity
trying to think of the process the
bloating stuff like that and we can
still tell roughly how long it's been
the longer it's been and this is good
for writing the longer it's been the
harder it is to tell whereas we can say
we you know rigor mortis has set in so
but rigor mortis also sets out it sets
in and sets out it starts 12 14 hours in
but within a day or two if it releases
and goes out I may have my numbers a
little skew I apologize but still there
is a it starts and then it it stops so
you can save the if they're in rigor
mortis it's within this time period and
that would still work with a car fire a
car fire that just happened on the side
of the 101 freeway you're gonna have a
respondent immediately so you're you
know you'll probably have my witnesses
that you know this happened almost
instantaneously you will not be able to
I don't know if this is part of the
question you will not be able to
ascertain how long was the car fire or
anything like that you can tell if they
died before the car fire interesting
fact though if they're searing of the
lungs yet this is at autopsy if they're
sharing of the lungs they breathed in
the flames if there's no searing then
they weren't breathing when they died so
they may have passed away from a heart
attack car caught on fire because it
crashed and burned so you know you can
tell if they were alive or not when when
they hit the thing so that's one way of
incorporating that
you